hey guys in this video I want to talk
about blackstrap molasses okay what is
it this is though a waste product from
sugarcane now they do make molasses from
beet sugar which I don't like because
most of the beets nowadays in the US are
GML okay but the point is that unsub
lack strap molasses comes from typically
comes from sugarcane so here they take
out this refined product which is pure
white sugar okay and brown sugar is just
a little bit of molasses okay but then
they shoot away this waste product where
they just sell it as molasses molasses
is where you have all the nutrients
specifically the minerals certain B
vitamins
I mean it's rich with potassium and zinc
and silica and the trace minerals
massive amounts so it's really I think a
good product and a small amount for kids
or people that are not trying to lose
weight and don't have a blood sugar
problem I know some people are like well
can I start having this and like we'll
hold on just use it as needed as a tool
to solve a problem if you want like a
spike of minerals but again it will stop
weight loss because it does have some
carbohydrate a little bit of
carbohydrate and they're not compared to
white sugar but it does have some sugar
in there because they haven't completely
taken it out but here's the point I
I like the benefit of this in certain
situations with women that have anemia
specifically if they have like a fibroid
issue or heavy bleeding with their
cycles this is probably one of the best
sources of iron okay so that's one
indication and the other one is that for
kids that are hyper and they're like
running all over the place and eating
all this white sugar white sugar
depletes you of potassium and minerals
blackstrap molasses puts it right back
in potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it helps the nervous system
it helps apply to fight system it calms
the nervous system down the Tassie 'm
helps you store sugar in your liver as
glycogen and how
so you go longer without those dips in
the blood sugar issues so it's good for
certain types of low blood sugar issues
but black mass a black sunsoft word
means that it doesn't have the sulfuric
sulfur dioxide that they put in there so
it's a lot healthier if it's unsalted
and again you know keeps them in your
fridge use it if you have anemia make
some recipes for your kids or yourself
occasionally if you're not trying to
lose weight but I think it's a really
good remedy and natural remedy because
it has so many minerals and thanks so
much for watching and before you go
click the link below and take my quiz
and find out the root cause of your
problem